[Musique]
cher journal je regarde de vieilles
photos et la nostalgie me fait
complètement oublier que j'allais moins
bien avant aujourd'hui que cet
instantané a fonctionné puisqu'il n'a
pas du tout capturé ce dont je ne
souhaitais pas me rappeler
je me demande si c'était mieux avant à
cette époque où j'avais si peur de la
presse ou si c'était mieux avant mon
avant il ya 50 ans quand on était obligé
de se déplacer pour des rendez-vous sans
intérêt quand il y avait plus de hubert
que du beurre
quand c'était pas hyper cool d'être
suivi par des gens quand c'était pas
hyper simple de partager des photos
inintéressant tiens regarde ça c'est
boeuf bourguignon j'étais hier tu es
superbe ça c'est le chou farci que j'ai
fait pour marcel est content mon doigt
pissos est passé à 2 2 chez hervé quoi
il bel et bien tu montres rien eu enfin
a aussi attend chez ça regarde c'est mon
chien dans 50 ans à lumignons bon je te
laisse pour bien montrer des photos de
mon frigo et avoisine à bout tu le
connais non je me demande si c'était
vraiment mieux avant quand être une
femme est restée chez soi c'était pas
tellement un choix quand nos parents ne
pouvaient pas dire que c'était mieux
avant parce que ben c'était la guerre
tout simplement et que les parents de
nos parents ne pouvaient pas non plus
dire que c'était mieux avant parce que
c'était aussi la guerre et que les
parents des parents de nos parents ne
pouvaient pas non plus dire que alors
pour le coup je passais calais en
histoire mais je crois que c'était pas
fou waouh qu'est ce que c'est parce
qu'ils habitent
ok pourquoi
juba j'avais rien demandé en fait très
vilaine éclairage en plus je me demande
qui j'aurais été avant pourrais je
trouver de quoi être nostalgique ou bien
me serais je dis que finalement ça sera
peut-être mieux après
[Musique]
trépigne trains complets
m